ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
creative commons license.
Your support will help MIT Open
Courseware continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last few lectures,
and we started to see some of
the consequences and looked
at simple changes,
transformations of expansion
and mixtures
of liquids and gases.
And saw how in the framework of
statistical mechanics, we
could derive the thermodynamic
results that you saw before,
based on an empirical
framework.
On the thermodynamic framework
we've been
working with all term.
But you saw them derived from
a microscopic perspective.
Now what I want to do is move
to examples that are more
commonly encountered
in chemistry.
One that we did last time
actually was very common, or
is at least a prototype
for something common.
That is we looked at what would
be a simple model for a
polymer with different
configurations
available to it.
And just tried to understand
what the basic thermodynamics
is that it would exhibit.
What the heat capacities would
be in various limiting cases.
High and low temperature.
I want to continue that today.
But for an even more
common case.
So the model that I want to lay
out is indicated on your
notes for today.
And essentially, you
could look at it as
double stranded DNA.
Any kind of polymer with
a whole variety of
configurations.
Ultimately what's going to
matter is what is the set of
energy levels available
to the system.
And so here's what
it looks like.
The way I've tried
to depict it.
I'm imagining something like,
covalently bonded chains that
have links between them.
So of course, it's reminiscent
of DNA with hydrogen bonding
between the strands.
And the idea in this simple
model is that you can have
various numbers of these
hydrogen bonds.
So this is the case that
would be the most
energetically stable.
That is, all the available
hydrogen bonds are formed
between neighboring pairs.
So this would be our
lowest energy.
Now let's starts breaking
some hydrogen bonds.
And what I'm imagining is they
break starting at one end and
working their way down.
So the next highest energy
state would be like this.
So now these are still
hydrogen bonded.
This is not.
And there's a cost in
energy for breaking
that hydrogen bond.
We'll call it epsilon zero.
It's a positive number.
So that this is higher
energy than this.
And now we'll go to the next
one, which could have two
broken bonds.
Broken hydrogen bonds.
And so on.
And if we imagine that this is
very long, there may be many
many, members of the chain.
Then of course this sequence
of structures with
corresponding energies might
go on for a very long way.
So this is a simple construction
that gives us a
set of states with distinct
energies.
And so we have a series of
configurational energy levels.
They're evenly spaced
in this model.
So there's zero, E
zero, two E zero.
And so on.
So those are available
energy states.
And now, just based on that
simple model, we should be
able to figure out all
the thermodynamics.
We should should be able
to figure out what the
equilibrium energy is at a
particular temperature.
What the average energy is.
And so forth.
And we can do it in a
straightforward way.
So we'll start with our
molecular partition
function, as always.
So it's q configurational.
And it's just a sum over our
available states with their
associated Boltzmann factors.
So sum over n of e to the
minus En over kT.
Now the way I've modeled this,
there are no degeneracies.
Each energy level has just one
microscopic state of the
molecule corresponding to it.
So there are no molecular
degeneracies.
Turns out we'll be able to put
this into a simple form.
So the first thing is, let's
approximate that we could take
the sum -- not to some finite
level, which would be the case
if there's a finite number
of elements in the chain.
But all the way through
infinity.
And the idea here is
the following.
We'll assume that the
chain at least has
a great many members.
Even if it's finite.
And then at some point, this
becomes a really small number.
Even if epsilon naught, the
energy of one of the bonds, is
less than kT.
Once we multiply it by a very
large number n, it becomes
very much greater than kT.
So the underlying assumption
here is, well there will not
be a significant number of
molecules in the highest
energy state anyway.
In other words, the terms higher
than a finite but large
value of n between there and
infinity are going to be so
small that those terms will
contribute negligibly to the
sum anyway.
And on that basis, we could
make this approximation.
And the incentive to make this
approximation and carry the
sum to infinity is that then we
can put this in what turns
out to be a very simple
closed form.
So now if we just write out a
few of the individual terms in
the sum, it's one plus
e to the minus
epsilon zero over kT.
Plus e to the minus epsilon
zero over kT.
I'll write this as squared.
e to the minus two
epsilon zero over k t.
And so on.
So this has the form of a sum
that looks like one plus x,
plus x squared, and so on.
And because the sum goes to
infinity, we can simply write
it as one over one minus x.
Sort of a very simple result.
And now putting this back into
x, it's one over one minus e
to the minus epsilon
zero over kT.
That's our q zero.
Our molecular partition
function.
So this model yields a
particularly simple
result for q zero.
And then everything else
follows from there.
So then we can write the
canonical partition function
capital Qn.
It's just q configurational to
the capital Nth power, where
capital N is the total number
of these molecules.
So it's just one over one minus
e to the minus epsilon
over kT to the Nth power.
And then we can start writing
out the results for the
various thermodynamic
properties.
So A configurational is minus
NkT, log q configurational.
That is, remember, A is minus kT
log capital Q. And this is
just going to come
straight out.
So it's minus NkT
log of little q.
Minus NkT, log of one over
one minus e to the minus
epsilon over kT.
Or positive NkT, log of one
minus e to the minus
epsilon over kT.
So a pretty simple form for
the Helmholtz free energy.
And I'm not going to write out
all of the individuals
thermodynamic terms, but I'll
write a few of them.
So mu, the chemical potential
for these configurations, is
just dA/dN.
With T and V constant.
And so the only capital
N dependence, the only
dependence on the number of
molecules is multiplicative.
Right here.
So this just gives us kT log
of one minus e to the minus
epsilon naught over kT.
And the important point to
realize here that we mentioned
last time too, in the examples
we considered then, especially
the last one, is that because
the only place that N figures
in is as a multiplicative
factor.
What this is telling us is that
we just have a chemical
potential, of Helmholtz free
energy per molecule.
The molecules are
all independent.
The total energy doesn't depend
on any interaction
between this molecule and its
neighbor somewhere else.
So terms like this are
simply additive.
So if we work out the chemical
potential, it's just one over
N times A.
And I'll just write the result
for u configurational.
Because I do want to look
at the heat capacity.
So it's Nk T squared, d log of
little q configurational / dT.
With N and V held constant.
And it turns out to just
be N epsilon zero.
One over E zero over
kT minus one.
So now we can look at
the heat capacity.
Cv configurational.
So it's du configurational
/ dT.
With constant N and V. And
taking this derivative with
respect to temperature.
Gives us an expression of
the following form.
It's Nk epsilon zero over k T
squared. e to the E zero over
kT, over e to the E zero over
kT minus one squared.
Just taking the derivative
in the usual way.
Now, this looks kind
of complicated
for the heat capacity.
But let's take a look, just like
we did last time for the
simpler case that we treated
then, let's take a look at the
high and low temperature limits
of what happens to the
heat capacity.
So at high temperature, well we
can start by just looking
at the energy.
That has a form that's
fairly simple.
So when temperature is large,
this is small, and we can
Taylor expand it.
So then we're just going to
have one plus epsilon zero
over kT minus one.
Which means the ones
will cancel.
And we end up with a fairly
simple result.
So u configurational, in
that case, is just NkT.
The epsilon zeroes are
going to cancel also.
And what that says is that the
heat capacity -- and of course
we could take the limit of this,
but we can just take the
derivative of this
with respect to
temperature more easily.
So Cv configurational.
It's just N times k.
In other words, the heat
capacity in the high
temperature limit
is a constant.
Last time we treated a simpler
case, where there were only
four configurations altogether
available, to this sort of
simple polymer model
that we drew.
Unlike this present model where
we're saying there are
essentially infinite number of
configurations and different
energies available.
So many that the highest ones
we're never even going to
access, because they'll be
much higher than kT.
Here it's different,
so now we have --
You know before, when we had
a limited number of total
states, remember what happened
in the heat capacity at high
temperature.
What was the limiting case?
Finite number of states.
What's the heat capacity
at high temperature?
This is going to
be on the exam.
What's the heat capacity at high
temperature, if there's a
finite number of states
available?
STUDENT: Zero.
PROFESSOR: It's zero.
What was the low temperature
limit of the heat capacity?
STUDENT: Zero.
PROFESSOR: It was also zero.
Right.
And the idea was for
a system with a
finite number of states.
The idea was -- so let's say,
the way we had it before,
there was one state
with energy zero.
And we had three states with
some energy epsilon zero.
And that was it.
Those were all the molecular
states available.
So we looked at the two cases.
In one case, when the high
temperature limit where kT is
much bigger than any
of this stuff.
In that limit, the molecules are
just equally likely to be
in any of these states.
Because there's much, much more
thermal energy than this
energy difference.
And the molecules are constantly
getting kicked
around by the available
thermal energy.
So if you raise the temperature
a little bit more,
it doesn't make any
difference.
The molecules already
are evenly
distributed among the states.
There's no additional
configurational energy.
So du/dT is zero.
It can't increase any more.
So in that case, the high
temperature limiting heat
capacity is zero.
And in the other case --
In the low temperature
limit, now let's say
kT is really low.
It's much less than
epsilon zero.
So now we'll redraw
this as zero.
And put the epsilon zero
states up here.
And kT is here.
Well when it's like this, the
temperature is so low that
there's not nearly enough
thermal energy to populate any
of these states.
And if you change the
temperature by a little bit,
it's still not enough thermal
energy to populate any of
these states.
So once again, du/dT is zero.
You change the temperature and
the configurational energy
doesn't change.
So the heat capacity
is zero again.
This is why it's so informative
to measure heat
capacities.
Because you can learn an awful
lot about the intrinsic
structure of the material.
What are the energy levels
available to it?
What do they do?
You can learn a tremendous
amount about that by making
measurements of the
heat capacity.
Well, now we're in
a different case.
We have a whole set of evenly
spaced energy levels.
Never ends.
So now let's look at the
high temperature limit.
But we're never in a limit
that's higher than the highest
level, because we're assuming
it goes on forever.
So it's up here somewhere.
There's kT.
So what happens?
Well if you raise the
temperature, there still are
higher lying levels that can
be populated, and that will
get populated.
So du/dT isn't going to be zero
in the high temperature
limit, in this case.
But it stops changing
at some point.
Because nothing's very different
about this than
having kT be, let's say,
up here or up here.
So in the high temperature
limit, yes, the energy does
change with temperature.
But it changes in the same
way at any temperature.
In other words, the energy is
just linearly varying with
temperature.
And the heat capacity is a
constant. du/dT doesn't change
anymore, once you're in the
high temperature limit.
Now without me writing any
expression on the board,
what's the low temperature limit
of the heat capacity
going to be in this case?
Going to be on the exam.
STUDENT: Zero?
PROFESSOR: Zero, that's still
going to be the same, right?
Put kT way down here.
That's just like this, right?
Not near enough energy to
populate even though lowest,
you know, the first level
above the ground state.
Change the temperature a little
bit, still not enough
thermal energy to
get up there.
So the energy doesn't change
with temperature in that low
temperature limit.
So you can immediately see
what's going to happen at low
temperature.
Any questions?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
will still be n k t, and
then it's just --
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So, of
course, that's a
limiting case here, right?
That happened because in the
limit of high temperature,
then this exponent is
really small, right?
So then you can Taylor
expand it.
In the limit of low
temperature,
this is really big.
This is nearly zero.
So e epsilon zero is much bigger
than kT in that case.
This is big.
This is negligible, right?
Oh.
Wait a minute.
Something's making
me real unhappy.
I can't have this right.
Ah.
Yes.
It needs to be zero, is
what it needs to be.
What am I thinking?
Of course.
It's one over a huge number.
It's zero.
OK.
So of course you can't
expanded it.
It's just, this is much
bigger than this.
This is an enormous number
at that point.
So in other words, what it's
saying is the configurational
energy is zero, because
everything is stuck in the
ground state.
And it stays zero if you
vary the temperature.
So you get the zero limiting
value for the heat capacity,
and the energy itself
is also zero.
Other questions?
OK.
Let me just make a few comments
about the entropy.
So I didn't write
it out before.
And I'm tempted not to
do it again, but I
suppose I'll do it.
So it turns out to be Nk, minus
log of one minus e to
the minus epsilon
zero over kT.
Plus epsilon zero over kT.
Over e to the epsilon zero
over kT, minus one.
And this comes from combining
the terms for A and u.
It comes from minus A over T.
Plus u over T. And what I want
to do is look at its limiting
cases also.
In particular, what happens
here in the limit of high
temperature.
And what happens turns out to be
k log kT over epsilon zero
to the Nth power.
Or put the N over here.
OK.
And what this is telling us
about is the number of
available states.
Roughly, how many states are
there that are accessible to
the system at some
temperature.
So in other words, think of it
as -- let's put the N back
there. k log of kT over epsilon
zero to the Nth power.
And think of it as k
log capital omega.
Where that would be
the degeneracy.
Now all the states are in equal
energy, but remember for
the whole system, remember
we discussed this before.
How you have a very, very narrow
distribution of system
energy states at equilibrium.
So you can think of this as the
degeneracy of the system
states that are actually going
to exist at a particular
temperature.
So if we look at the limiting
value of the partition
function, it's just
kT over omega.
Or the same thing for
capital Q. kT over
epsilon zero, sorry.
To the Nth power.
So you have a very simple
expression.
And so again, what this is
doing, is it's giving us a
measure of about how many
states are available.
And it's particularly
informative to look at that
for the molecular partition
function.
What it's telling us is, if
I look at kT over epsilon.
And these levels, remember,
are evenly spaced.
So here's epsilon zero, two
epsilon zero, three epsilon
zero, and so on.
It says, you know, if kT is
about ten times bigger than
epsilon zero.
So this is ten.
It's telling us, roughly how
many states does the system
have thermal access to.
The molecular state.
It has about ten states.
So going over to our picture of
the set of structures, you
could have anywhere up to
about ten bonds broken.
Now, the individual molecules
are going to be in a whole
range of states.
Some of them will have fewer
than that, and some of them
will have more than that
number of bonds broken.
But on average, it's going
to be about that number.
And then, if you look at the
whole system, the number of
states available, of course
it's astronomical.
Because you have to take each
molecule, and say, well it
could be in any one of
something on the
order of ten states.
And then whole set of N other
molecules can be in the states
they might be in.
Change the first one,
and do it again.
So you have this astronomical
number of system states.
But remember, like we discussed
once before, it'll
turn out that although the
individual molecule states
vary considerably with energy,
the system states, which are
averaging over some astronomical
number of
molecules, where capital
N is something
like ten to the 24th.
Once you average over that many
individual molecules, you
find that there's very,
very little
fluctuation in the energy.
In the system energy.
The individual molecule energies
vary considerably.
Realistically the variation of
the molecular energies -- that
variation is going
to be comparable
to the energy itself.
To the average energy.
So if the average energy is
roughly you know, the ten
epsilon zero, you say okay,
how much might it vary?
Well, there are going to be some
molecules that have only
a couple of bonds broken,
and some that might
have 20 bonds broken.
The variation will be on the
same order of magnitude as the
average itself.
But then you average over
capital N of them.
And then you immediately
discover that there's very,
very, very little variation.
And in particular, what happens
then, is, you know,
for molecular average energy,
epsilon zero, and variance, or
standard deviation about
the same magnitude.
System average energy is
u, and it's going to
be capital N times.
Well let's say that
-- average --
Oh sorry, let me not
put the zero There.
It's just average energy.
And the system average energy
is just N times
the molecular energy.
But the system variance is going
to be on the order of
the square root of
N times epsilon.
If you've done statistics,
then you've seen
that sort of result.
You do a bunch of samplings a
capital N number of samplings,
and the variation looks
like the square
root of that number.
So what ends up happening
then, if you look at the
relative variation, you might
look and then say, well it's
pretty big.
This is ten to the 12, right?
It's still a huge variance.
But let's compare it
to the average.
So this is ten to the 24th.
This is ten to the 12th.
It's on the order of ten
to the minus 12.
An incredibly tiny fractional
variation
in the system energy.
You could never --
There would be no practical
way to measure it.
And of course that is
consistent with
what you would expect.
If you say let's measure the
configurational energy of a
bunch of molecules in a liquid
solution, or molecules in a
gas floating around.
And it's a mole of them, that
total average energy is not
going to fluctuate
significantly, even though
individual molecules that you
pick out of that whole system
might have quite widely
varying energies.
And that's the point.
So it's an incredibly
small variation.
Now you can derive this.
I didn't derive this,
of course.
I asserted that this
is the case.
And it's probably familiar to
some of you if you've seen
some statistics.
But the way you would derive it
is, you know in addition to
calculating the average energy,
the average of E, you
can also calculate the average
of the energy squared.
And you can calculate the
standard deviation that way.
You calculate the average
of E squared.
And then you minus the average
of E, the quantity squared.
Take the square root.
That's your root mean square.
And that's what leads
to this result.
So it's pretty straight forward
to calculate it also.
Alright.
So any questions about just the
extent of variation of the
individual molecule energies
or the system energies?
Okay.
Then, now what I'd like to do
is look at another kind of
energy that's going to turn out
to have exactly the same
set of levels that
we just derived
from this simple model.
And some of you may have
seen this before.
Many of you may not have.
And for right now, I'll
just assert it.
But it will illustrate why
this is so useful.
It turns out that if I've got
molecular vibrations -- you
know, there's nitrogen and
oxygen in the air.
If I look at those nitrogen
vibrational energy levels.
Or oxygen energy levels.
They look like this.
Evenly spaced, non degenerate
energy levels.
So the model that we've
constructed here, based on
this simple two-chain polymer,
actually gives us a set of
energy levels that maps directly
onto the vibrational
energy levels of a molecule.
So all the results that we've
just seen apply, not just for
conformations of a
polymer, but for
vibrations of a molecule.
So everywhere where it says
configurational, you can just
write in vibrational.
And you'll still be right.
because of course, what
matters is what are the states
that are available to the
system, and what are
their energies?
After that, the formalism of
statistical mechanics takes
over, and calculates partition
functions and
thermodynamic functions.
The input into that is states.
And their energies.
Well, we have the exact same
set of states and energies.
So we immediately arrive at a
super important case and its
results for molecular
vibrations.
And not only molecular
vibrations, but vibrations of
a crystal lattice.
Acoustic vibrations
of a glass.
Or even a liquid.
So there's an enormously wide
ranging set of results that
we've derived by starting
at this simple picture.
And when you take quantum
mechanics, you'll see that
indeed you do get this set of
evenly spaced energy levels.
You may well have seen the
results before, and you'll see
it derived there.
OK.
Given that, then I want to
talk a little bit further
about the heat capacity.
So we've seen the limiting cases
for the heat capacity.
Namely, the low temperature
limit is zero.
That's the case whenever you
have quantized levels.
You can always get kT lower
by far than the
lowest excited state.
So that everything is stuck
in the ground state.
How low that is depends
on how far apart
the states are spaced.
But there's got to be some
temperature somewhere that's
down there.
So we've seen the heat capacity
limiting cases.
Let me just sort of
draw them again.
So here's kT much less
than epsilon zero.
And up here, kT is much bigger
Now I'm just going to sketch
the full temperature
dependence.
In other words, I'm going to
connect those two limits that
we've seen.
So here's what that
looks like.
And I'll write it
as vibrational.
So we know it's got to be zero
at the low temperature limit.
And we know that it's this
constant value in the high
temperature limit.
It's Nk.
And in some way, it
smoothly connects.
And if you look at the actual
scale, here -- so here's kT
over epsilon zero.
Here's the limit of
low temperature.
Actually, you don't have to be
very high above epsilon zero
to be in in this high
temperature limit.
So if you look at the plot
that's on your notes, this is
already -- it's not quite
leveling off precisely.
But it's already pretty close.
When kT is just two times
epsilon zero.
It's already almost at
the limiting case.
Now this has tremendous
significance.
So a long time before quantum
mechanics was developed,
people made measurements
of the heat
capacities of materials.
And they were familiar with the
fact that when you got to
ordinary temperature -- room
temperature, the heat capacity
was temperature independent.
And that was understandable
for reasons
we'll discuss shortly.
Basically, in that case, the
heat capacity -- it's not just
Nk for one vibrational mode.
Of course, that's what I
describe for a single
vibrational mode of,
say, a molecule.
If you have a crystal lattice
with N atoms in it.
Let's say it's an
atomic crystal.
Each atom has three degrees
of freedom.
It can move in each of three
independent directions.
And there are N of
those atoms.
There are 3N total degrees
of freedom.
That's how many vibrations
the lattice has.
So in fact, you have to
multiply this by 3N.
So what would be seen is,
you'd have 3R, the gas
constant, per mole,
in other words.
And if you looked at Cv
over 3R, then this
value would be one.
Very useful to see that.
To figure that out.
And people understood it.
What people didn't understand
is this stuff.
Why did it do that?
That was a great mystery.
Why did the heat capacity go
to zero at low temperature?
And the reason they didn't
understand it is because the
model for vibration
was really simple.
The lattice is a bunch of
masses and springs.
I know the vibrational energy.
And I can calculate it.
That is, I know the classical
vibrational energy.
Remember, the reason it
goes to zero is this.
It's all because of the fact
that the energy levels are
discrete, quantized levels,
with gaps in between them.
If I've got classical mechanics,
then that means
it's vibrational energy.
The energy just gets bigger if
the amplitude get bigger.
It's not discrete,
it's continuous.
There are always energies
in there.
In that case, there's never
a situation like this.
Where kT is lower than the first
available excited level,
and everything's in
the ground state.
That never happens in classical
mechanics, because
there are always levels there.
But it does happen in
quantum mechanics.
And Einstein recognized that
this was a way to explain this
low temperature limiting
heat capacity.
So actually if you look at early
development of quantum
mechanics, really it
was all predicated
on statistical mechanics.
And the idea that, well, that
you could then do the
statistical mechanics with
quantized levels, just the way
we've done it.
And what you immediately
discover is, gee,
it all makes sense.
You go to low temperature,
everything's stunk down here.
And suddenly you've got zero
heat capacity, because you
changed the temperature a little
bit, and everything is
still stuck back here.
So that's the vibrational heat
capacity of a solid.
That's what it looks like.
And at moderate temperature,
this doesn't have to be very
much bigger than epsilon zero.
You're already in, essentially,
the limit.
The high temperature limit.
And now for molecules, that
limit isn't usually reached at
room temperature.
Here's a kind of calibration.
kT at room temperature is
about equal to 200
wave numbers.
So molecular vibrations, you
know, you've taken IR spectra
they're typically on the order
of 1,000 wave numbers or so.
kT isn't bigger than the
vibrational energy.
But a crystal lattice, you know
the vibrations are the
acoustics vibrations.
And those are much lower
in frequency.
If you have an atomic crystal,
it just has the sound
vibrations at all the different
wavelengths that are available.
They're never very high.
So it's easy to get into
the high temperature
limit, in that case.
Where you basically
see a temperature
independent heat capacity.
OK.
By the way, this was actually
used commonly to determine the
molecular weights of
molecular crystals.
Because you've got a factor of
the number of moles in there.
If you ask how big is
the heat capacity?
Well it does depend on
how many moles of
material you have.
Because it depends on
how many atoms.
That control how many modes
there are in the crystal.
How many vibrational modes.
Because each atom has 3N
degrees of freedom.
So if you just weigh the whole
crystal, and then you measure
the heat capacity, you know how
many moles there are, and
now you know the weight,
you can figure out
the molecular weight.
OK.
So that's the low temperature
limit.
And now I want to talk a little
bit further about the
high temperature limit.
And in particular, I want to
talk about both the heat
capacity and the energy
that we've seen.
Namely, this thing.
Of course it's really the same
result for the energy and the
heat capacity.
They're obviously intimately
connected.
So these are the high
temperature limits.
Now it turns out that that high
temperature limit doesn't
just obtain for vibrations.
But it's also the case for
molecular rotations,
translations.
All these low energy
degrees of freedom.
So let's see why.
It has a name, that result.
It's called the equipartition
of energy.
Sometimes it's called the
classical equipartition of
energy theorem.
And what it says is one half
kT per degree of freedom
equals energy in the
high T limit.
And in particular, for
translation, so E
translational is 3/2.
Well, NkT for N atoms.
Or molecules.
E rotational is, now it depends
how many rotational
degrees of freedom there are.
If I've got a linear molecule,
there are only two.
It can rotate this way, and
it can rotate this way.
If I've got a non linear
molecule, parts all over the
place, it has three
unique axes.
It can also spin this way.
And that's a rotational
degree of freedom.
Of course the linear molecule
wasn't like that.
Nothing is moving when
you do that.
So it's either NkT, linear.
Or 3/2 NkT.
Non linear.
Great.
And then E vibrational is NkT
per vibrational mode.
That's because vibrational
energy is potential and
kinetic energy, and
it's 1/2 kT each.
Why does all that
stuff happen?
Turns out, you can see
why pretty easily.
All those degrees of freedom.
Those classical degrees
of freedom.
If you say, let's write out an
expression for the energy.
Classical.
You know it's 1/2 m v squared.
Or it's 1/2 k x squared.
Or for rotational energy it's
1/2 I omega squared.
You see a functional
form emerging here?
That looks similar in
all these cases?
You know, 1/2 times some
constant, times
some variable squared.
Well, now let's look at our
expressions for the energy.
Average energy.
We're going to sum over all the
energies of epsilon i, e
to the minus Ei over kT.
Over sum over i, e to the
minus Ei over kT.
That's just how we originally
derived the average of energy.
In other words, it's the
probability of each state
times the energy
of that state.
Summed up over all the states.
Well, now we have an expression
for the energy.
It's one of these things.
It's something times
a variable squared.
So, we'll use some general
functional form, a y squared.
And now, let's assume we're in
the high temperature limit.
And we've seen what
that means.
It means kT is big,
compared to the
separation between the energies.
When that's the case, there
are lots of these
terms in the sum.
We can convert them
to integrals.
We can forget about
the fact that the
energies are discrete.
We can say look, they're
so close
together, compared to kT.
That we can turn the sums
into integrals.
So then we have integrals
instead of sums.
And here's our energy.
It's a y squared.
Whatever that is.
It could be this, it could be
this, it could be this.
And it's not going to matter.
e to the minus a y squared
over kT over, integral over e to
the minus a y squared over
kT. dy, dy.
OK.
And here's what's
going to happen.
If you do this integral
by parts.
This one.
What ends up happening is it
gives you this integral times
a certain number.
This is going to come
out of the integral.
And so it will turn out.
And it's straightforward
to do it.
It's in the notes.
It goes through.
But I'll just write
the result here.
The result is that you get, in
this high temperature limit
where you've gone to the
integral form, you get 1/2 kT.
And it will always
be the case.
All you need to know is the
form of the energy.
As long as that's the case --
Remember y is just a variable
of integration here.
That's not going to
be preserved.
This comes out because
of what happens here.
So what that's telling you is
whenever you have an energy of
this form, and you're in the
high temperature limit, then
you get this classical
equipartition of energy result.
So, for translation, of course
there are three separate
degrees of freedom.
For velocity in the x,
y, or z direction.
For rotation, if it's a linear
molecule, let's say there are
two separate degrees
of freedom.
You have to keep track of
how many degrees of
freedom there are.
But that's all you have to do.
That's enormously powerful.
It means that without doing
anything, I know the average
translational energy of the
molecules in this room.
Because of course I'm certainly
in the high
temperature limit.
With respect to translational
energy levels, they're really
closely spaced.
Same with rotations.
Now at room temperature
vibrations, forget it.
I have essentially no
vibrational energy.
I'm at the low temperature
limit for the molecular
vibrations of nitrogen
or oxygen.
Those are high in frequency.
So much higher than
200 wavenumbers.
But for each molecule,
I have 3/2 kT of
translational energy.
Linear molecules, I have kT
of rotational energy.
Without doing any work at all.
And since that applies to most
molecules at room temperature,
it's an incredibly useful, very,
very general result.
OK.
Next time we'll do a little bit
of chemistry, and look at
phase transformations.